c'est la guerre des mots et de l'image
qui se poursuit entre donald trump et
joe biden le président sortant appelle
ses partisans à inverser le scrutin
alors que la victoire du démocrate à la
présidentielle a été officiellement
certifié mardi en pennsylvanie avec la
certification des comptes par le
gouverneur de cet état américain
ils se battent déclare le président élu
donald trump at-il vraiment perdu at-il
épuisé tous ses recours c'est l'objet
d'un autre face à face ce soir et pour
en débattre nous sommes avec eric
semaine chargée de relations médias pour
les républicaine saut vers 6 friends
bonsoir et casquettes merci d'être avec
nous théo lobry animateurs du groupe
bernie sanders france bonsoir à vous
aussi
donald trump qui appelle donc ses
partisans à inverser le scrutin alors
qu'il a donné son feu vert pour la
transition c'est une nouvelle
provocation à l'égard de son rival théo
lobry oui bah disons que c'est un petit
peu à l'image de ce qu'il fait depuis
plusieurs mois voire même depuis
plusieurs années puisque déjà dès 2016
il avait dit qu'il ne reconnaîtrait pas
la victoire d'hillary clinton
j'ai envie de dire par là que c'est
simplement un fait de plus
alors certes c'est ses marques en ça
rentrera dans l'histoire puisque c'est
sûrement une des premières fois qu'on a
un déni pareil de la part d'un président
je rappelle qu'il y a quand même plus de
6 millions de voix d'écart entre eux joe
biden et donald trump alors certes c'est
un collège électoral mais on voit que
les scores termine à 306 grands
électeurs pour joe biden et 232 me
semble-t-il pour donald trump donc c'est
une victoire qui est assez large dans
les états on est à + dans les états
serré on a entre 10000 et 50 mille voix
d'écart donc nous ne sommes plus du tout
dans le cadre
de 2000 entre george bush et al gore où
ça s'était joué à une centaine de voix
en floride
donald trump je crois n'admettra pas sa
défaite puisque ce n'est pas dans son
caractère mais les institutions
américaines tiennent bon la démocratie
américaine a tenu bon et malgré tous les
mensonges alors qu'ils sont ensemble
dangereux pour la suite
puisqu'une bonne partie des américains
en particulier des électeurs
républicains croient donald trump sur
parole malgré le fait qu'il ait perdu et
que toutes les institutions reconnaisse
sa défaite
mais après tout bon vin l'essentiel
c'est simplement qu' une passation que
donald trump soit là ou pas pour la
faire après tout ce n'est qu'un détail
en tout cas officiellement annoncé un
perdant dans l'état de pennsylvanie rond
la 10 6 ce qui n'a pas empêché de le
faire réagir écouter ça a été un scrutin
frauduleux elle ne pouvons pas laisser
cela se produire
nous ne pouvons pas laisser cela se
produire pour notre pays et cette
élection doit être inversée
parce que nous avons gagné la
pennsylvanie de beaucoup et nous avons
gagné tous ses états clés de loin de
donald trump votre champion n'arrive pas
à digérer sa victoire à aix peine que
cherche-t-il selon vous ils cherchent en
terminer avec le l'historique bien
connue des démocrates de de tricher aux
aux élections présidentielles je vous
rappelle qu'en 1960 c'était le président
eisenhower avait dit à nixon de
contester l'élection car il y avait eu
des tricheries temps dans la ville de
chicago que dans l'état du texas de
winneden baines johnson et depuis ce
temps il ya toujours eu des
irrégularités et je dirais dire qu'il
n'ya pas de dire comme ça proclamer
qu'il n'y a aucune preuve
2 comment de fraude électorale à
philadelphie ce équivalent à dire qu'il
n'ya pas de preuves de fraudes
électorales à marseille ou à nice
chicago c'est l'équivalent vieillit les
niçois théo lobry qu'est ce que vous
répondez à eric semaine quand vous dites
voilà
c'est gonflé d'apparent gros des
démocrates de parents connaître les fros
nous lui dit quoi et que ces fraudes là
elle représente absolument rien c'est
c'est toutes les études le montrent
c'est ce que c'est ce que c'est ce que
je j'avais déjà dit la dernière fois
c'est que c'est moins de 0 01 % des voix
qui sont frauduleuses alors certes quand
il ya des fraudes il faut les punir
mais c'est toujours à la marge d'une ça
ne change absolument rien d'ailleurs
c'est marrant de voir mon contradicteur
ce soir républicain parler de tricherie
démocrate alors en rappelant kennedy
alors c'était c'était effectivement une
autre époque et puis nixon avait aussi
très certainement mis la main dans le
pot de confiture comme on dit mais il
faut se rappeler qu'en 2000
c'est bien le scandale il est là bien
avec bush qui gagne la floride
son frère jeff boucher gouverneur de
floride
la cour suprême tranche plus ou moins en
faveur de george deubeuliou bush et al
gore
sachant que l'amérique va cirer si
jamais ils allaient un petit peu plus
loin dans la contestation du résultat a
préféré céder céder la victoire à son
adversaire
bon ça entraîner derrière l'invasion de
l'irak et toutes les les problématiques
militaire au moyen-orient peut-être qu
al gore à cette époque là on aurait pu
aller un peu plus loin mais en attendant
aujourd'hui l'écart est tel qu'il n'y a
aucune contestation possible vis-à-vis
du vainqueur c'est joe biden point c'est
tout maintenant j'y verrai comment des
preuves vidéo tomb raider et paris c'est
un petit peu compliqué de laisser la
parole aux autres m si les républicains
amène des uniquement des preuves vidéo
qu'ils ont retrouvé sur youtube ou sur
des comptes twitter qua none puisqu'on
sait que il ya une filiation entre le
président américain et mouvements
conspirationnistes qua none
bon ben si ça ça sert de preuve et que
c'est suffisant dans ce cas là pourquoi
pas la justice trois jours après jours
contre donald trump pour la 35 35 e
procès entre guillemets perdu par
l'équipe présidentielle
rudy giuliani qui à l'époque était
considéré comme le maire de l'amérique
aujourd'hui se révèle être un avocat
médiocre eric sehn comme vous l'avez dit
c'est un débat donc chacun se laisse
parler et l'ex peine la réponse à notre
bon on est complètement bafouée par un
barça a eu l'idée était content
d'entendre d'entendre ça le fac et cela
fait quatre ans que les démocrates
répète à tue-tête qui a eu des
tricheries pendant la l'élection de 2016
monsieur contient nous dit aussi qu'il
ya eu des tricheries en 2010 c'est à
chaque fois qu'elle est républicain cc
by tricherie c'est de la fraude
électorale moi messieurs on va pas se
mettre d'accord pardonnez moi on tourne
en rond parce que personne n'a rien vu
encore d'accord sur le fait de qui a
triché n'est pas ce soir qu'on va
convainc élucider cette question mais
j'aimerais vous poser une question quand
même avec ses 6 millions de voix d'écart
est ce que ce n'est pas plutôt le le
coude après qu'un cherche à faire donald
trump finalement aujourd'hui on dit que
le 36 mhz c'est désormais un courant
politique c'est pas cinq cherche la
stratégie c'est pas ça la stratégie
justement de votre poulain ben je suis
on est étonné que le trump étaient en
train de gagner toute l'élection toute
la nuit soudain au milieu de la nuit
philadelphie et trois autres villes
fermées le comptage des voix s'est
immiscé on n'a jamais vu ça ni en
amérique ni dans un an ni en france ni
dans aucun autre pays
et quand ils reprennent le matin parce
que personne n'a bien sûr aucun
démocrate m'était resté là dans les
bureaux pendant la nuit soudain voilà
que joe by day mais devant et nous
sommes tous censés croire cela rappelle
jean ramel pendant quatre ans on les
gens s'étaient pas cannon c'était les
démocrates
il a fait il
il a travaillé avec le russe assez
booting qui l'a fait gagner et mouloud
la seule chose qu'on dise ce qu'elle est
c'est que les villes démocrates ont
triché et comment ils en font du fonds
comme le font depuis longtemps une belle
lurette laboratoire chicago et
philadelphie n'ont pas eu de maires
républicains depuis 70 ans
et là le meilleur la meilleur exemple
c'est la nouvelle orléans le paillis de
mer est plus qu'un depuis 1876
mais non non non c'est jamie et jamais
de tricherie alors le truc à joe biden
lui veut tourner la page america is back
nous dit joe biden c'est son slogan pour
cette toute nouvelle étape je vous
propose d'écouter son message je sais
mais nous devons nous rappeler que nous
sommes en guerre contre le virus devrait
pas les uns contre les autres on trouva
les uns avec les autres
ouais la lutte contre la crise sanitaire
la priorité aux états unis désormais
alors que joe biden n'est pas encore
installée à la maison blanche est ce
qu'il ne grille pas trop vite les étapes
théo lobry je ne pense pas c'est le
problème numéro un aux états unis comme
comme ailleurs dans le monde cette crise
sanitaire
et il a bien raison effectivement
d'anticiper notamment il a encore plus
raison d'anticiper puisque donald trump
lui met des bâtons dans les roues
c'est tout à fait normal c'est le
président élu il prendra ses fonctions
dans environ deux mois
c'est normal qu'il anticipe cette sortie
aussi importante de joe biden les états
unis qui sont de nouveau prêts à guider
le monde
théo lobry tout de même que doit-on
comprendre avec cette sortie un petit
peu surprenante guider le monde
eh ben c'est quand joe gaiden parle d'
america is back
c'est en opposition bien entendu america
first de donald trump c'est un retour
dans les instances
multilatéralisme comme l'onu l'om est-ce
l'unesco c'est avant tout ce genre de
choses
à quoi il faut s'attendre à dire que
quand on est guide on est devant et on
monte exemple aux antes normalement ben
c'est ce que c'est ce qu'ont fait les
états vis que la seconde guerre mondiale
depuis quelques années alors c'est pas
propre à donald trump
mais les etats-unis se désengage du
multilatéralisme et si joe biden peut
recourir on voit du multilatéralisme et
aux instances internationales pour
essayer de de guider le monde alors
c'est une formule très américaine je
suis pas sûr qu'en france on est
forcément envie d'être guidé comme des
enfants mais en tout cas ce qui est
certain c'est qu'aujourd'hui avec le
désengagement des états unis et
l'arrivée de la chine le monde et risque
d'être guidés par les chinois dans les
décennies à venir et je ne sois je ne
suis pas certain que ce soit est très
très bonne chose et une très bonne idée
xn effectivement est ce que les états
unis ont encore les moyens de guider le
monde et ça sera la dernière question
bon et bien sûr ils ont ils ont les
moyens de guider le monde déjà donald
trump avait guidé le monde 2 pour partir
de la chine qui ont toutes les économies
tous les pays occidentaux ont ouvert
leurs économies leurs secrets secrets
militaires aux chinois et c'est bien sur
ce que va leur faire joe biden avec son
fils future ryder qui avait décrit
dernier des millions de la part des
chinois ou delà de la femme de l'âme du
maire de moscou
et c'est bien sûr ça va ça va reprendre
le com comme ça et nous on avait une
vision d'un hymne amériques qui se
laissait pas ce père qui vend des parts
ou à la base ce que j'ai aimé chez mon
contradicteur ce dès qu'ils disent il va
mettre des bâtons dans les roues de
dubaï
les démocrates ne sont rien d'autres que
de mettre des bâtons dans les roues des
jobs de danse depuis quatre ans et mais
là c'est sensé les trois héroïque penser
un républicain qui le fait voilà qu'on
s'arrête plus
quand qui gagne c'est le populaire c'est
le populisme qui gagne pas c'est un
gauchiste y gagne c'est la démocratie
qui gagne c'est la même chose qu'en
france vous mettra pas d'accord en tout
cas messieurs eric dane et théo lobry
merci d'avoir accepté ce débat en direct
sur rt france merci à vous deux